regardez kg et la regarder comme idée
pour regarder comme il est beau c'est
son anniversaire van hamme
c'est gentil de le rappeler oui si
lourdement mais france auquel vous avez
64 ans au jour des débats et franchement
je nous souhaite aux uns et aux autres
d'avoir repris physique aux ménages ah
ouais ouais c'est un très beau nom c'est
difficile le matin quand je me regarde
alors on s'est dit que pour votre
anniversaire mon cher bernard il fallait
qu'on fasse un cadeau dingle je suis
curieux de savoir ce que c'est alors la
voici les séries là je me méfie cyril a
beaucoup réfléchi ces dix bourses est
vrai qu on en parle souvent ça a été
l'un des événements de la télévision ya
quelques années c'est vidéo gag
ah oui cela fait 14 ans et 14 ans a
tenté avec des records d'audience ah oui
6,7 millions 7,6 et les spéciales samedi
soir jusqu'à 12 millions ah oui tout ça
n'arrivera plus jamais jouer alors j'ai
donc des fiches pour vous on va on va
lancer le générique de vidéo gag et vous
allez suivre le conducteur alors voyez
vous n'aurez pas de prompteur sabre et
un prompteur là vous n'aurez pas à la
sphère crois que c'est plus intéressant
c'est l'improvisation la crise et
génériques mais on est les violences à
l'école
[Musique]
où
voilà c'est drôle il ya des moments mon
petit chien faro que j'adorais vous avez
fait ça quand vous comptez démission
ouais je redis ça non non alors merci
les amis d'être fidèle à ce rendez vous
que nous vous proposons chaque fois sur
tf1 c'est vidéo gag bien sûr même après
18 ans vous êtes toujours là je vous en
remercie c'est comme ça que je peux
acheter une maison alors nous allons
nous allons sommes voir et revoir les
vidéos les plus drôles que vous nous
avez envoyées par cachette cassettes vhs
et bien sûr une fois n'est pas coutume
on commence avec nos chères petites
têtes blondes et c'est vrai que je
disais ça à l'époque ça m'énervait avait
alors avoir des enfants si vous savez
bien c'est une sacrée responsabilité moi
je sais pas je n'en veux pas donc au
regard des annonces et chichi comme ça
dans la vie
alors il faut garder un oeil sur eux en
permanence sinon dès qu'il s'échappe de
votre surveillance ils ne peuvent pas
s'empêcher de faire des bêtises et wee
aa annoncé qu'elles ont rigolé oui
depuis des décennies vient d'y accoler
mire et netease jeu là je fais pas au
niveau de la poitrine
alors oui c'est plus fort qu'eux ne
supporte pas les enfants qu'on leur vole
la vedette
eh bien nous allons leur faire plaisir
car tout de suite ce sont eux les stars
bravo donc kevin thomas manger chez vous
[Musique]
elle était notre père dia le masque je
suis chewbacca touchback à elle que tu
me vois
j'ai compris gamin gauche droite et
percute
évidemment tout est est ce que ce serait
possible rapporte s'il vous plaît et ça
marche toujours
et ça marche toujours sympathique c'est
vrai quand on voit comme ça vous savez
j'adore les animaux ils sont doukkala
affectueux enfin en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on croit en général derrière une
petite boule de poils se cache parfois
un véritable monstre
pire encore certains d'entre eux sont
vraiment très mal élevé la preuve avec
cette nouvelle séquence qui ne manque
pas d'air
super mariani ou est-ce que j'ai foutu
ses clés michel était dégueulasse mais
vas-y la chance à bien prends ça dans
les dents gamins des poteaux face à
tours 2
ah bon tu crois vraiment toi tu es dans
ta jalousie moi je suis dans mon jacuzzi
[Musique]
et c'est que tu cherches tu sais que tu
cherches à errer retient pour ça et et
aux attentes en rien mes petites soeurs
layati tiers ses détient développe et
heures oui alors c'est ne sais pas c'est
votre famille c'est l'inversé alors vous
ne vous était pas seul
en plateau ou non il y avait un chien
j'avais mon chien comme gomis l'avocat
farouk marois d'or que j'adore
oui oui pendant 13 ans s'est dit qu'il
vous faut il faudrait aussi pour
anniversaire un chien chien et chat là
on a on en a trouvé un
c'est une verdoucq g verdict est ça
c'est c'est trop mignon c'est bien me
fais vieux je fais bien oui c'est
impressionnant alors trompé on peut
alors combien vous nous refusez par jour
non il est propriétaire a fait ses
besoins ce matin des coiffeuses et par
jour 2a d'enregistrement way 5 6 5 6 par
boris la branche m'a barré après un mois
en vacances à moi en vacances et il vous
était bien payés c'est très bien pu
hélas vous ai dit 80000 euros par mois à
peu près ah oui quand même
oui je t'emmerde c'est vrai et c'est
vrai nom mais c'était d'abord une très
bonne émission assez bon merci on ne
sent pas le cul des gens jeunes et déjà
des gens qu'on était dans le monde c'est
didier références cinématographiques à
wisques ou des mois j'ai un petit sur
dix 10 points j'ai une question à vous
poser est ce que cette émission vous à
fermer des portes à tf1 oui tout aurait
été vacataires fois partout à par tous
et si vous voulez c'est un
divertissement même si les gens regarder
beaucoup il y avait 6 7 millions de gens
ils avaient raison celle des rigolos oui
et puis il peut évidemment penser qu'on
était très simple et avec de bannu avec
la belle olivia adriaco donc forcément y
penser les gens pensaient qu'on était
incapable de faire autre chose donc
j'étais enfermé dans cette émission
c'est pour ça que j'ai gueulé que je
suis parti c'est tout ce temps oui alors
pour nous raconter là
non je n'ai pas besoin il a été arrêté
il ya eu il ya eu quand même hein on
voit enfin les milieux comme un drame
c'est que de banales époque donc animé
avec vous oui l'élection moto tragique
et ils étaient reboisées paritaire oui
il a eu un été embauché par delpérier
avec la légende
là les gens ou là la légende dit que
alexandre delpérier a beaucoup insisté
pour le remplacer
c'est vrai ah oui ah oui c'est vrai oui
c'est à dire que malheureusement donc
alexandre debanne lâché sérieux qui est
une grande amie qui était formidable
avec moi depuis le début depuis des
années c'est moi qui l'avais choisi avec
dominique cantien ouais on avait repéré
sur m6 où il avait une émission et donc
on a engagé ça s'est très très bien
passé avec lui et effectivement il a eu
cet accident dramatique le jour de la
fête des pères où il allait enfin
retrouvé son père et se réconcilier avec
lui d'ailleurs
et en fait il était presque mourant et
un jour delpérier a débarqué en disant
on va écouter j'ai vu de ban l'hôpital
alors que moi aussi je voyais de ban à
l'hôpital qu'il ne pouvait pas parler
toute façon il souhaite que ce soit moi
qui le remplace donc j'en parle à
etienne mougeotte qui était le patron de
tf1
étienne me dit marc si tu veux hockey le
pourquoi pas à l'essai on le prend juste
le temps qu'ils reviennent
manque de pot à l'exemple de ban s'était
très sérieuse sa durée de trois ans sa
rééducation et il arrive beaucoup de
courage il s'est bien remis mais bon sa
durée de trois ans donc pendant deux
trois ans j'ai eu alexandre delpérier ça
s'est bien passé
merci merci vite pris olivia adriaco
après l'appel en abris alors vous devez
continuer votre armée lors le problème
qu'on a c'est qu'on appelle ton nom
c'est pas un débutant le temps encore on
aurait pu s'arranger mais en fait la
machine qui doit envoyer le sait bien
alors je ne savais que je raconte
quelque chose alors je peux alors je
sais on me dit que ça remarche a alors
lancé moment de rendre hommage à nos
anciens potes voilà est-ce qu'on est
d'accord voilà alors si on est d'accord
et oui
nos papilles de nos mamies ne sont
jamais les derniers pour nous faire une
bonne blague
et oui c'est donc le moment de rire avec
eux ou malgré eux en tout cas sur le
podium de l'humour le troisième âge
arrive toujours en tête frappait pas mal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais il faut que tu mettes de le bon ben
on a d'un coca et tu vas voir ça a fait
un truc magique tu vas adorer
crois moi je ne bouge pas ta moustiques
et milou mon téléphone je sais combien
chacun des sadiques et il est où mon
téléphone
rendez moi mon téléphone voyous au
téléphone il est où le match surtout
leur voix au téléphone un témoin malam 1
au débaut les tient une remise et dans
cette lettre la mamie regard des
primates comme une très jolie dans mon
style est très joli mais on dira unicorn
est toujours rien
we are over plateau est alors souvent à
la fin malheureusement d'envoyer plus
les gags ont amené jusque a rigolé alors
là c'est donc voilà la suite j'ai vous
dire il ya une cérémonie qui n'échappe
pas aux aléas c'est évidemment les
mariages en parle évidemment il y en a
connu 4 et ce n'est qu'un début et je
suppose
d'accord d'accord alors tout de suite
prenant la direction de l'amour pour le
meilleur et pour le rire bien sûr
ou quand le plus beau jour de notre vie
devient à la notre pire cauchemar et
nous on a fait des textes aussi mauvais
quelle époque si vous avez c'est quoi si
les mails mais c'est les même assez
drôle je vais me regarder ces prêts
chérie ça fait des années que nous
sommes ensemble et j'aimerais faire une
chose je suis sous ce nom mais je m'en
veux
[Applaudissements]
attends je crois que tu as un accroc sur
tarbes à tour c'est mon cher si on sait
gérer ce scénario aso je suis assez bon
toi bien elle a pris 3 gouttes c'est bon
c'est bon c'est trois de série je vais
leur faire une arrivée mon gamètes et et
après c'est bon c'est bon tu quand je
tente là non je t'offre si je tourne à
laisser vos jetons mais attention hein
de caisse qu'à fois c est toujours le
pote c'est pas possible
donc tout ça fait 3 de tomber
franchement je vais vous dire la vérité
ça va oui mais le progrès skis ça peut
plus marcher maintenant parce que c'est
toujours sur les réseaux sociaux
et oui on de ça c'est plus beau c'est
pourquoi vous avez arrêté parce que ça
marchait bien ça marchait très bien j'ai
donc j'ai quitté la chaîne puisque je me
suis engueulé avec eux j'étais en passer
par jed saborder s'ébattent saborder oui
j'ai été remplacé par sébastien folle et
et voilà avec olivia adriaco et voilà
mais c'est pour ça c'est que c'est de
façon l'émission s'est arrêtée très vite
vous pouvez pas continuer toute façon
alors je rappelle que les textes étaient
écrits comme par laurent baffie
ah oui mais quand même quand ma fille
quand même un thème pas que je le dise
ma fille
merci beaucoup mais alors oui ce beau
cadeau que vous êtes fait oui de revivre
ce moment fort qui nouvelle jeunesse
pour moi qui étais vidéo gag et non